before we go we are very pleased to
announce our new partnership with
Gretchen Rubin you know her and her
award-winning podcast happier so every
Monday we'll share one thing you can do
today to live a happier healthier and
more productive life research shows that
46% of people are just overwhelmed by
their to-do list and 60% or so
overcommitted they can't even finish
everything on the list New York Times
bestselling author Gretchen Rubin she is
here with a better alternative to shake
up your to-do list
Gretchen good to have you here but you
know all the experts say many experts
say the to-do list everybody should have
one right and a lot of they rethink that
rethink their because sometimes you may
be resisting the to-do list you get
overwhelmed when you look at it you feel
discouraged and you don't want to move
forward so there's there's other things
that you can do one size does not fit
all yes the to-do list isn't working for
you you can try other ways list
Kadal aside like this analysis
especially if you're working on a big
project you feel like I've been working
and working I'm not making any progress
write down everything you've done tada
the word in the mirror will help you
make $2 right yes it's encouraging it's
energizing
yes you know sometimes I write things
down that I've already done just so I
can yeah them out can feel so good yeah
you say it could do lists yeah I thought
that was some people don't like to be
bossed around even by themselves on
their own to-do list so instead of it's
to do list you do a could do list or a
might could list you do it you can do it
if you feel like it or not it's up to
you but there's also the Today list
which I guess is the urgent math yeah if
you're overwhelmed just what you have to
do today is enough don't think about
tomorrow just focus on today and all of
these tools will help you be more
productive
yeah and help you use the lists of the
way that's right for you alright so
every Monday we're gonna take a page out
of your philosopher to people I'm just
gonna say tada into the mirror
that'll do it for us Thank You Gretchen
we will see you tomorrow on CBS this
morning sitting right here all our
places bright shiny faces a kitty his
day